okay so uh
starting from just some sort of
quenching maneuver okay
and then working uh on
the fear reaction cycle okay so i'm
gonna shove him and
the untrained mind will push back on me
okay he doesn't want to be shoved so
uh go boom he enters and i'll take it
so again i'm here
i push he pushes i go in
make sure that you don't stop me
and then you do your keyhole
okay so he's gonna do that same
strategy okay so he pushes and rather
than me
uh resisting i take him into the kazushi
into the kazushi pattern okay so he goes
to push
and i'm gonna start turn
he goes to push and i start to turn
so when push 10 he goes to push
start are you going to see or
you won't find the uh question nugget
try push hard
it's not there
so neutralize this energy go
start to turn
okay okay
okay so uh struggle
is me yonging against his young
it's me being reactionary to him
that that's what you're seeing here
and struggling harder so he
struggles harder so i do the yield push
please so i do the yield
is the strategy amongst the unawakened
what we're doing now is i
am i'm very why why am i not relaxed i
relax
i'm relaxed nothing's happening it's no
different
than if he has me inside control
he's very tight there's nothing to do
just relax don't don't shove on him
just wait just relax he has to move
sooner or later as he tries to do
something so that's where my space is
go
so struggle happens internally first
as the unawakened state as the
reactionary state as being
bonded to the fear cycle the fear
reaction cycle
so as we go here and he goes to
do the strategy this is what happens as
i'm unawakened i
push back on him i stop him doing what
he's doing
and that's what sets up his koshinari
woah i'm in
what we're doing in aikido is as
he moves i don't brace
he moves and i move
[Music]
or better said
he moves me or better said
it just moves
so he's going to try very hard to
trigger me
that's what i don't want to do
he goes to trigger me and
i'm letting him move he goes
and then as i become more relaxed i
become
more sensitive so he goes and
you can feel when he's gonna go
he goes
so he falls into though not that
is which what he expects but he falls
into nothing
and again i'm disconnected he goes
so treat it as an emotional drill
it's not any different than going you
look stupid with that haircut
he has no reaction just here
there's no reaction he goes he's always
going to just fall in the air
[Music]
i release
myself from that fear reaction cycle
can you feel that
okay the external or let's put it this
way
the way that is dependent upon the
external
is not the way so
uh if he comes he comes to get me and
i'm like don't struggle don't struggle
i am struggling internally
i'm struggling because i'm dependent
upon not engaging
the way is internal
i don't have to be struggling
if i'm in the clinch if he's pushing on
me
just like
you may experience pain but suffering
is optional it's the same thing here
struggling is an internal thing
contesting is an internal thing
it's not a thing that is resolved
externally okay so
with this in mind we'll go back to the
elbow pass
okay so we're going to go slow first he
goes to push
i start to turn and i take this here
so he goes a little slower i
absorbing start the turn
relax and i have it right there
so i'm going to open it up and first
show the body
you're fine okay so
his body goes and i'm absorbing
start to turn and i'm starting to disarm
the elbow by bringing it inside
as i'm disarming the elbow my head
is going to open his fingers
he goes wool and body clears
when i have my arm in place or here
on my arm here it's not
shoving this down
it's just sticking to him one
two three there it is
back in place boom this
is irrelevant to what i want so
one two
there into the technique
don't let yourself panic here and do
some sort of
force move reconcile it
one
disappear
this is different go
[Music]
different
very far
okay so uh you're going
go and you're here and it's stuck
and then you gotta have this apparently
overly complicated move okay
he's tying his push-pull strategy
and i think my heel he's in it
[Music]
it's not complicated so
first i have to make sure i'm not
contesting
every time i contest i slow myself down
and i generate friction young young
generates friction
so he goes and i yield and i let him
fall into the technique so wash this
hand
this hand no don't grab it
stick to it a little slower here he goes
i'm matching him boom
turn that's where it was that's where it
stays
then bring your other arm to that arm
don't go here and look
right there
this hand now take this off
this handy goes body is moving
boom catch right here
so my body is throwing it
right to the other hand
just like i was gonna throw a ball of
that hat
boom right there
can i combine the two slower please
[Music]
boom to there to here
here we go
then don't tighten anything
until you can tighten it it's in place
with that
sometimes it's not exactly perfect
you still have the dynamics
boom keep it and you'll
find it this hand didn't close it's
still doing what it needs to do
you'll find it in the technique
then it will close
but if you open it up he goes
no it's not gonna happen you're going
around his energy
by accepting his energy
okay so again we're going to do the
elbow pass he goes
i start the fight attorney i'm going to
grab here
so let's open it up again this hand
goes right into there
so last time i passed it
there this time i'm going to pass it out
here
same same pasta
and grab and i'm in
uh
same yield
again knock here
disappear
[Music]
use what you have so as you go
elbow pass you see
here even though the shoulder grabs the
throw
you can add to it with the elbow too
okay so we started this with a push
triggering right so we learned a more
inviting way of moving so
i don't push against his push okay so
in this technique i'm gonna use that
same strategy against him
so he goes and i deviate
and i'm gonna push and he's gonna do
what
yes you see you're gonna push back into
me is when he pushes back into me then
it goes over
requires a guy to open back into the
technique
it's not a not a guy standing there
um he's trying to go
back that way
so we're here home deviate
push pass and i'm in the technique
again all of you except one or two
will be triggered so i go here and shove
them in
you guys will respond back and then you
can use that to train you okay
so whoa
technique okay